Two uninhabited Pacific Islands more than 5,000 miles from the UK one has been inhabited by 14
British men while a separate island was home to 14 British women they've been utterly alone
with only the clothes they stand up in and a handful of basic tools filming everything
themselves the women have made it off alive tonight it's a final installment of the men's
island you lazy bunch of bone idle bastards survival
will be harder than ever they'll have to endure the height and harsh tropical storm season this
island either wants to decompose you or eat you alive they'll have to find their own water and
hunt for their own food with the finishing line in sight have these modern-day men got what it
takes to survive I'm gonna go to hell for this
five weeks ago 14 British men were dropped on a remote Pacific Island
they've had some success with their fishing nets
but not enough to stop their physical decline
we've been here over a month now we are starting to starve be careful taking huge risks and the
pursuit of food holy he's severed one of his tendons the group suffered their biggest loss
he needs to be evacuated as 36 year old Will was forced to leave the island
I feel devastated he's gone of all the people he wanted to finish with he was up there wasn't it we
didn't finish strong as the team and now the islands thwarted that I hate this place I hate it
we're in again
no respite for us man
thunder we're getting screwed again
fair weather Islanders what's going on here oh I've got a flippings as a scorpion right don't move
don't move don't move I do not want to get stung of course you don't right please be quick about it
whoa let me get that way don't cut it off don't throw it off on your spot take it off take it off
give it a shot yeah ain't that the thing with this island one minute it's all calm and then
the men have been living on the island for an unprecedented 36 days and they're now entering
uncharted territory and that's why this time only the mentally strong are going to make it to the end
foreign
living for five weeks on an extreme low calorie diet consisting mainly of fish limpets and coconuts
the men have been getting weaker by the day pounds just keep dropping off gentlemen
to make sure their physical decline doesn't become life-threatening Dr
Piers has been monitoring their weight using scales from his medical kit come on you have a streak of
piss that puts me uh just under
Er, ten stone.
My bollocks weigh more than that.
Jesus.
28-inch waist.
Jesus Christ!
You could just buy boys clothes when you get home now.
If you have a flap suit, pack it.
Baby gap, mate.
You could baby gap.
Since arriving on the island,
the men have shed nearly 30 stone between them.
The weight loss was always going to be dramatic,
but I was not expecting it to be as severe as it was.
A maybe just maybe.
The storm has been kind and dropped us a fresh coconut.
Determined to halt the decline,
the men redouble their efforts to find food.
We're going to go and check the shit out of these nets.
Good luck, fellas.
Oh, my leg is just not working today.
I had that yesterday, just...
Have you worn your boots recently?
No.
Oh, God, dude, do not try putting them on, I tell you now.
Huh?
Oh, it's a bit weightier than last time, isn't it?
The fishing nets have been a lifeline for the men,
but as they get weaker,
taking the raft out to check them
has become an increasingly difficult task.
Come on, now, let's have just one or two.
Oh, bollocks.
Little snag.
Oh!
Oh, this is getting annoying now.
Today, there isn't a single fish
to reward Charlie and Piers for their efforts.
You all right?
I think it's dangerous now, actually,
moving these nets, in all honesty.
All of us are just skin and bone,
and it's not really...
I don't think it's safe any more.
We've eaten almost every single coconut on this whole island.
All the ones left are pretty much gone.
They're pretty much rotten.
This was the last little stash I knew about.
Depleted a lot of the limpet stores already, really.
Even the men's once-reliable food sources
appear to be running dry.
We have truly decimated the fish
within three metres of the boundary of this island, haven't we?
24 hours ago, we were...
..conquering this island.
Nets were full of fish.
24 hours later, we're in tatters.
This could go from bad to worse very easily.
Every single one of these guys is going to have mega low moments.
It's just the reality of being out in the wild,
being tired, being bitten to death, being hungry.
You just have those moments.
And one of the key lessons I've learned is that the pain,
the discomfort, it never lasts forever.
Keep your eyes on the light.
Can I just show you something?
There's something here that you might all want to see.
Where is it?
Come with me. It's not very far.
It's worth it, Sam.
Is it edible?
It's good.
I'm taking my knife, just in case.
It's Bear Grylls, isn't it?
And it's a hope as well.
Look at this.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, baby turtle.
It's alive and it's making its way to the beach.
And if there's one,
there's probably a few more.
Isn't that amazing?
That's incredible.
There's the others. Look.
Oh, the other one. Oh, yeah.
Can you see the two of them?
Yeah.
Oh.
It's gorgeous, isn't it?
Privilege.
It's a real privilege, isn't it?
I just noticed it.
I was coming back from the end of the beach.
I just saw this thing wriggling in the sand and I thought,
what's that?
And just to see that, it's absolutely amazing.
This is such fire.
You can sort of see them toasting in the sun, can't you?
Yeah.
It's the life and death of these guys, you know what I mean?
It's like each one of us, you know,
whether it's here on this island or in life,
we're sort of fighting our own personal battles.
Should we help him?
Come on, mate. Get out of that hole.
Help him along.
Come on, chap.
Go.
And maybe I'm doing a completely wrong thing
and...
Shoot me down, but if there's a chance of this little dude
living rather than dying,
I want him to live.
Go on, little fella.
Take to the water.
God, that was one of the most incredible things I have ever seen.
Really touching.
Those guys have just been born, they've just been hatched.
All they're thinking about is just surviving.
Getting to that water, it just puts everything into perspective.
Such a beautiful sight.
This is what life is, really.
You OK?
Yeah, yeah, tired, that's all.
The turtles have been a welcome distraction,
but after more than five weeks on a starvation diet
and no sign of their next meal, the men are in bad shape.
God.
Tired.
Just tired.
I'm so tired, just tired.
I've usually got lots of energy, and I like being enthusiastic about things.
I like doing things.
But I've been so tired.
I'm sort of starving, wasting away, and I know my body is just like,
you need fuel, but there's no escaping it.
You're so aware that you're going downhill fast.
Are you all right?
No, he's gone, I think.
They're all fucking dying.
On the beach, some of the baby turtles are also on their last legs.
They're just frying up hot little bodies.
I wish they'd woken up at night.
It breaks my heart, but either we leave these little guys to rot
or for the birds to pick at them or we eat them.
And this, by any definition, is a moral dilemma.
Are we definitely boiling these little birds?
Yeah.
Little buggers up, are we?
What do you think?
I'm not eating it.
No?
I think it's disgusting.
I think you're all inhumane if you eat them, to be honest.
The turtle who died on the beach, there's rumours of that going in a broth,
and you could say for ethical reasons or whatever,
there's no way I'm drinking any of that at all.
I'm going to go to hell for this.
Despite strong feelings in the group, Sam makes a decision.
Eat, not eat.
I think we should eat them.
I think these guys are done.
Are they all right?
I've got a hard-boiled egg.
Hates Christ, they're beautiful, aren't they?
Oh, that's wrong.
That is so wrong.
I've eaten some fucked up shit in my time.
This takes a kick.
Salute, my little turtley friends.
Best shell in all?
Yep, every bit.
Raphael.
Michelangelo.
Is there anyone else claiming these turtles?
Go on, then. Don't be shy.
I'll have two.
Oh, my God, they're good.
They're absolutely stunning.
Are you eating them or not eating them?
I am not eating them, mate.
All right, OK.
Weird how you can feel nothing for a snake or an iguana,
and baby turtle has died anyway.
It's weird.
Difficult to eat.
But I scoffed them down.
It is quite delicious.
I'm sure it is, but a bizarre principle that I'm sticking to now.
With only half the group able to bring themselves to eat the baby turtles,
they bring little relief to the malnourished men.
It's becoming an experiment in starvation.
It's really tough to keep going when you're so hungry.
And the future looks pretty bleak when it comes to food.
The men have now been living alone on the island for more than five weeks.
It doesn't smell too good.
Oh!
Ah!
Fuck!
Since the demise of their fishing nets, the food situation has become critical.
Resources on our back doorstep have run out.
A handful of dead baby turtles provided a temporary reprieve for some of the men.
Whoa!
But today they're back to nothing.
About a week ago, we saw a baby turtle.
We saw pig-trotter marks, and we're keen to lay some pig traps.
And hopefully, we'll be able to bring back the bacon.
When you're deprived of food, it literally becomes all-consuming.
It's all you think about.
It's all that motivates and drives you, I need something.
But hard though it is when they're running on empty,
the men can't afford to neglect the other survival essentials
they've worked so hard to maintain over five weeks, especially team spirit.
We're on of the most draneling Chuck Santiago brothers
Because I'm trying to find what they could get.
Come on, chefs.
That chap's is delicious.
Is that the obligatory pubic hair?
After an unsuccessful morning,
the only meal the hunting party have been able to muster is limpet broth,
which is quickly devoured by the men.
Mm.
MMM!
I think Phil's the biggest fool.
What have I missed?
The group's oldest member, Phil,
has arrived back in camp later than the others.
We all served up the food
and completely forgot about Phil.
What are you doing?
Is there any driveway?
That'd be a negative.
What I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna hide behind my T-shirt.
Wow.
I know that he doesn't sit on it.
Does he need more than water now that he's...
It's the first time since the men arrived on the island
that they have forgotten to feed one of their own.
Everyone looked after themselves and forgot me.
Oh, my God, I'm so sorry.
That's OK. It just means that you all owe me.
That's all.
So, we weren't acting like this four weeks into the experiment,
but now we are...
We're coming up to five and a half weeks
and a lot of people are starting to fray around the edges.
Some of them are fraying.
Some of them are coming away at the seams.
She didn't hear me.
What's he doing now?
I don't know.
He's wondering now.
Have you completely lost it?
I don't believe so.
I miss Phil.
OK, finally, let's get the fuck out of here.
That's it.
Enjoy.
We'll see you later on, mate.
Desperate for a decent meal
and having exhausted the resources close to camp,
Sam Brown and Kyle head off to look further afield.
Now we can go get some coconuts.
Fingers crossed.
For the first time,
they're heading to the unexplored south side of the island,
an arduous five-kilometre round trip across unforgiving terrain.
Having set off at 4pm,
they have just two hours to make it there and back before nightfall.
We might have left this slightly late.
Guys, there's an iguana here.
Where is it?
In the remaining hours of daylight,
the other men are doing their best to find a meal closer to home.
Where is it?
It's in the fucking tree here. I'm pointing to it.
We're in a fucking forest. It's twirling.
It's a tree.
12 o'clock, 11 o'clock, where are you standing?
Wow.
Fractures occurring in the group.
Wee arguments, bickering.
And that's got to be down to the hunger and the tiredness.
We haven't got a fucking clue where it is.
It's... I mean, can everyone see me?
If you can see me, I'm pointing at it.
Where is it?
It's down towards you, Barney. Barney, Barney.
It's going that way. It's going that way.
Yeah, I know. He's gone.
Back.
Bollocks.
MUSIC PLAYS
MUSIC FADES
So are you struggling a bit, today?
Yeah, today has been a tough day, actually.
Sam and Kyle have now been trekking through dense jungle
for more than an hour...
..in an attempt to find out if the island's south coast
has any untapped sources of food.
Slippy as buggery here, Kyle, just be careful.
Cheers, mate.
This is going to be a fucking nightmare on the way back.
Thanks for that beat, chocolate.
Mate, be careful. Be careful, be careful.
Be careful! Be careful. Be careful. Be careful. Be careful. Be careful. Be careful, mate!"
Be careful.
This is a no-go.
We were hoping to find a nice sandy beach and a coconut tree.
Instead...
..we find this.
Fucking lethal.
One slip up here and we'll die.
We'll die.
On the other side of the island,
farmer Charlie is the first to return to camp
after a fruitless day's hunting.
Oh, fucking hell!
I've come back to find the fire down to about one square inch of embers
after a month of constant burn.
We're getting a bit complacent now.
How much water's left?
I don't know.
Oh, no.
You can see the standards of the camp are going lower and lower
because people are just starting not to give a shit any more.
Kept this fire going for a month now.
There was no smoke coming out of that whatsoever.
There was an ember about an inch square.
But it was either, yeah, Barney, Phil, Roscoe...
That's not point fingers, it's not helpful.
..just saying it was either.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
One of you five.
It cannot happen again.
Most of the group have now been back at camp for the past hour,
but Sam and Kyle have yet to return from their expedition
to the south of the island.
Are we worried about them, lads?
It's now pitch black.
It is, isn't it? Yeah.
It's not the ideal time to be out foraging.
My worry is, when you're in the middle of the jungle, in the dark...
Yeah, you've got no navigation.
You've got a high tide as well, so you can't even get round.
This is the first time any of the men have failed
to get back to camp before dark.
With the weather worsening
and concerns growing over Sam and Kyle's safety,
the men muster a search party.
Let's go. Let's try and find them.
Ideal.
Fucking sure we're going out at four o'clock.
Yeah, they're certainly not equipped for a night out
in the fucking jungle on their own.
WHISTLE BLOWS
It's a very steep drop down here.
Sam!
Kyle!
It's not looking good, man.
They would not find us here. Not a chance.
This is Kyle and Sam in the dark,
trying to trek back towards our camp.
We'll see how far we get.
With no sun in the sky, it's hard to get your bearings.
Really, really unforgiving terrain.
WHISTLE BLOWS
Charlie!
Sam!
Try the bird.
WHISTLE BLOWS
Oh, fuck.
This is fucking stupid.
I feel tormented out here.
WHISTLE BLOWS
Come on, boys!
SAM!
Kyle!
WHISTLE BLOWS
Having searched for an hour with no sign of the missing pair,
the group reluctantly head back to camp.
WHISTLE BLOWS
Truth's known you want to get them and give them a clip
for being so stupid and putting us all through this
because the only thing they can do is have a look at the dog.
The dog is a dog.
Oh, my God.
because the only thing we are going to be thinking now all night is how they say how are they i hope
they're okay familiarization makes you think that we've got it licked yeah that's what we've done
we ain't got nothing licked have we not mother nature in this island and bite you whenever she
feels fit oh four rocks oh yeah desperately trying to get back to camp sam and kyle have
hit the treacherous stretch of coast where will had his accident this is getting dangerous
one wrong move here could easily prove fatal
now this next bit
you have to take it really really slow because
it's slippy as hell in the boulders and we've only got one head torch between us
i am genuinely shedding myself now
i genuinely don't think that they know where they are
it's a bit eerie actually
sometimes maybe i've seen one too many horror films i didn't think i was scared
of the dark but out here you have to sort of steal yourself that you're not scared of the dark
hello i see a light boys
sam good to see you man we are so pleased that you're back i don't think i've ever been so
massively relieved in my whole life well done boys glad to have you all well done boys
well done boys my pleasure the two prodigal sons returned thank god they're back home safe and sound
the other side of the island is just horrible it's all sheer cliff yeah the waves hitting it like
it's going to sit down sorry listen sorry to keep you guys up for so long anyone but we got back
that's what counts well the past few days have taken the whole island off its way into the sea
whole group really to their limits both physically and mentally not only have
they forgotten to feed people and neglected the essential tasks of fire
and water but their recklessness brought the group close to losing two more men
if they don't start looking after each other thinking smart being resourceful
and surviving then got a cat's chance the whole thing for me all comes down
to that's getting complacent yeah about everything thinking that we're we're now
starting to own this island a little bit when really we have shit we took
control that comes down to slipping off rocks running out of wood which will
blatantly do tomorrow yeah whatever it may be let's just get our drills a
little bit back in order yeah let's get back with morning morning calls and
stuff like that let's get back into them because we're all fucking show you the
minute so let's get the basics right yeah it would be vulgar to finish in
such a weak way we are here and we have grown so close together that we go for
it
doing the things we want to do that are exciting and fulfill all them things
we've always wanted to whip since being here let's go for it let's do this chaps
come on I don't want to finish week when I finish strong catch some pigs catch
some animals finish this adventure the way we want to I'm not going out like a
wet fart I want to go out strong
mum and dad
there's so much I want to tell you because I just wanted to say being here
has made me realize just how much I love you all
I don't want you to be worried about me in any sense and the reason I'm being
kind of a little bit nearly tearful it's because I just can't wait for the next
for that moment to see you all.
But I'm having the time of my life.
I really am.
I hope, I hope, it's off to a good go.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Early morning.
After a difficult day yesterday,
the men are determined to redouble their efforts
and leave the island on a high.
I'm amazed what washes up on these damn beaches.
A snake.
Should I get a machete?
Nice shot.
Come on.
It's so funny, because on day one,
we would be like, oh shit, there's a snake.
And now we're like, oh, it's just another snake.
Roar!
Today, I really got a sense that our teamwork,
our team ethic really came back.
It just seems to be a real pulling together today.
Woo!
Man, he caught a whopper.
We've got fish!
Holy shit!
Hello, hello, hello.
Oh, what a night.
Oh, that is it.
It's a beauty as well.
Never in my life have I made my own sashimi before.
I've gone from eating one fish maybe every six months
to now having it raw on a beach, on a home-whittled table,
and loving it.
Dig in. To you, sir.
To many, to many more days like this.
Oh.
Mm.
That is just so...
Succulent in the justice, does it?
Fresh.
It's delicious.
One of the things I want to see in this experiment
is whether these guys can use all their collective resources
and brains and muscles to not just survive,
but to really thrive, to build community,
to have fun, to work out efficient sources of finding food,
to, you know, to really start to thrive
and separate us from the animals.
When Oinky makes his way to my front door,
I will consume the entire fucking animal.
The men's renewed spirit has brought fresh optimism
about the prospect of catching a meatier meal.
Ah.
What have we got here?
These look like little trotter mack's to me.
Oh, my fucking God.
That is exciting, isn't it?
We're going in the bushes, so, obviously,
it's a bit too hot for them, and then going back in.
They're definite pig trunks.
Please.
Oh, my God, bacon patties.
Oh!
We were all fantasising the other day
about what we're going to do to Oinky.
Delusions of grandeur, of smoking him,
and putting him on a spit, and having crackling, and...
God knows all sorts what we'd give for that.
Damn, it's warm, Barney.
It's getting hot, mate, isn't it, eh? Yeah.
Further down the beach,
Vik, Barney and the two Sams
are also on the hunt for a decent supper.
Shit the dog. Shit the dog.
What? Look at that. Look at that.
There's something there. Stop, stop, stop. Don't move.
Where, where, where? OK, stop.
Black pig, black pig. There's a pig in there. No way.
Don't move, don't move. Vik, Vik, don't move.
Let's have a think about this. OK.
He was just having a little snooze in the shade,
so we need to get behind him,
cos he's going to disappear straight in there.
I'll go up the sand. I'll go with you, then, yeah? Yeah.
Don't you worry. We'll hold him down.
If I'm eating pig tonight, I'll fight the bastards.
Just keep very calm.
When cornered, pigs can be incredibly aggressive animals.
This thing is going to run like stink.
They've got razor-sharp tusks and a vicious bite.
I'll go up to him and then...
There's a pig.
There's an other pig.
No!
Get in!
Holy shit, Barney! Sorry, Barney!
Woo!
I thought he was going to turn and bite me. I crapped myself.
Yeah, he's gone.
Gosh, that was so much quicker than I thought.
That was just like...
Listen, it's done. This is how we roll.
I wasn't expecting you to stab him.
I didn't expect you to stab him at all.
I did. Mate, that would kill you.
That would hurt. That would fuck you up.
Yeah.
This is a fucking adult pig.
This is like a hog, isn't it?
These things wreck people.
Jesus, look at that tusk.
That would go through to bone, wouldn't it?
Oh, yeah.
Six weeks ago, I would have been very slow to draw a knife
and ram it into a large mammal's throat.
Now, I didn't even think, I didn't even hesitate.
Oh, easy peasy.
OK. Yeah.
Oh, there's going to be so much meat on that head.
In 21st century Britain,
I think we're so used to getting
all of our meat pre-packaged off a supermarket shelf.
And in many ways, we've kind of lost touch
with actually where it comes from.
Meat on his legs, ribs, back legs, a lot.
Many people understand we find the whole idea of killing an animal,
they find it either cruel or definitely upsetting.
And, yes, it's never pleasant to take a life,
but in a survival situation, when it comes down to it,
it's a simple choice.
Them or you.
Nose to tail,
we're going to eat every piece of you, Mr Pig.
I can see home from here, boys.
I don't believe it.
I don't believe it. It cannot be a trotter.
Woo!
Boys!
Ain't done this thing, eh?
Yes.
Well done, boys.
OK, three, two, one, go.
Oh, Mr Piggy.
That was hard work.
Yeah?
And you've already got me big, good in there.
Oh, that is great.
Absolutely brilliant, isn't it?
Yeah, get in there.
A pig of this size, weighing up to 200 pounds,
contains tens of thousands of calories
and could feed the ten men for the next few days.
I think there's a lung there.
Yeah, you don't want to eat lung.
Oh, we're going to have pork belly.
God, that is like barbecue food.
Yeah.
Has anybody got any preference about who's served first today?
I would say Phil.
Yeah, great job, good luck.
After the group forgot to feed Phil yesterday,
by way of an apology, they give him first dibs on the spoils.
I'm having a meat orgasm.
Which one's the kidney?
Anyone that knows me will know one of my favourite meals is liver and bacon.
Guess what that is?
Liver.
Oh.
And then to add to that, kidney.
That beats any crocodile, any fish, anything I've had on this island.
I don't know what you're saying.
The pig is the men's first taste of meat in weeks
and nothing is going to waste.
I think that's testicle-y.
I'm going to eat everything of this pig.
I'm even going to eat it.
It's little Willy.
I'd eat some pig penis.
That's a very unique flavour in there.
Does that taste like dick?
Yeah. Yeah, it is dick.
It worries me quite a lot that you know what dicks taste like.
Vic! Yeah?
I think we're raising the sign, mate.
After surviving on the island for almost six weeks,
the men have decided to make a tribute
to their achievement.
Gentlemen, by the power invested in me,
I name this camp the Croc and Trotter.
The Croc and Trotter!
I'm really looking forward to this ending
and looking back and just saying,
wow, I did that.
I accomplished...
I succeeded.
We conquered the island.
We're named and ready to rock.
Shall we play toss the caber?
Yeah!
First game, let's go.
Three, a two, a one, toss my caber.
Come on, Charlie.
Man!
Oh, no!
That's it!
Go!
Yay!
One!
Not bad, son!
Not bad!
Yeah!
It's the first time that the whole group,
as we let our hair down,
are not worried about water or wood or survival
or will we eat or will we not.
It's kind of like, let's just get together as lads and have fun.
I wish, looking back, I wish we'd done more of it.
That's one of the highlights of our entire time here.
Oh!
Beautiful!
Go, go, go, go, Vic!
No, Charlie!
Oh, no!
Oh, no, no!
Oh, yes!
One nil!
Yes!
What I have experienced many times in the wild
is an incredible sense of achievement
that is very hard to get in everyday life.
Catch it!
Oh!
And I think when you battle for seven or eight hours
in a torrential rainstorm with just a couple of sticks to make a fire,
you've got to look for opportunities, however small, to have fun.
Yeah!
It's almost like nourishment, but for the soul.
Take the string!
Yes!
Call it a draw!
A draw, yeah!
A draw!
I feel amazing.
I feel relaxed, I feel empowered,
I feel like we're masters of this island.
I'll treasure this moment.
I really, really will.
This is what the island's all about.
This and a handful of other moments.
This feeling.
I hope we'll get to see it.
I hope I never forget it.
Well, here we are.
We are at the end of this magnificent, magnificent journey.
Overwhelming sadness that I miss my wife and kids so much.
Not so much sadness, just,
God, how long can this truly go on for?
Er...
Yeah, I'd like to see them soon, if possible.
Some of it better for me, some of it better.
What do you think of that beauty?
Shit. There it goes.
Look, look, look.
Ooh, there's some heat off this bad boy.
Look at this!
Look at that goal!
Didn't take long, did it?
Ocean's Elevenses.
This is our last night on the island.
Yeah!
Yes!
Good!
Best night so far?
I think so.
Has to be, doesn't it?
Awesome.
Love it.
Home's within spitting distance.
Really enjoying it.
Everyone's spirits are really high.
Wow.
The men have now survived on the island for 40 days.
Would you guys like to hear a little Ravi Varan's poem that I wrote this morning?
I would love to hear Ravi Varan's poem.
Yes, I'd love to.
Dear islands, our islands, this new family does hail.
As you've chucked every last, but nobody has failed.
On the contrary, dear islands, as our stay grew longer,
we may have reduced in numbers.
Holy shit!
But we've grown ever stronger.
For six long weeks,
we've battled hunger, tides, exhaustion, the weather.
But with British Bulldog spirit,
She floats!
we triumphed with heart, soul and endeavour.
Holy shit!
You've been cruel, uncomfortable and brutal to us all.
With freezing rain, dangerous seas and rocks that make us fall.
Holy shit!
You have dangerous beasts that can kill, maim and maul.
This is a scorpion.
But we baited, trapped, killed, cooked and ate them all.
Oh, delicious. So good.
But dear islands, our islands, we will never forget
the incredible journey we've shared since our new family met.
So the question is, our islands, can British blokes survive?
Get the fucking camera off!
The answer is no, dear islands.
We didn't just survive, but thrive.
Excellent.
Oh, my God, look at her go!
Wow!
So I'm on my way to pick up the men after six weeks, you know,
and to be honest, I'm pretty nervous just about what I'm going to find.
You know, are they going to be emaciated wrecks
or are they going to look pretty healthy?
You know, are they going to be broken men
or will they have figured out how to survive and thrive?
It is quite strange, though, isn't it?
What bit?
It's finished.
Yeah, yeah.
Within an hour, we'll step off and never be able to get out.
We'll step off and never, ever step back on.
For it has been an honour serving you, gentlemen.
Yes, see you here.
Good effort, gents.
I feel quite proud of our little gang.
The island has taught me an incredible sense of unity
and we've shared, we've shared everything that we've had here on this island.
It doesn't matter if it was the smallest fish,
we've shared it between everyone.
I feel...
..thrilled to have made it this far
with you all.
It sounds fucked up,
but I feel like I'm going to actually miss you lot.
I think I'm leaving the island with a renewed sense of confidence
and some friends.
Some more friends, should I say.
Here we go, boys.
Don't worry.
Here he is.
Yes!
Come on, lads.
This is our man.
This is it, lads.
It's Bear Grylls.
Very good, lads.
It's only Bear Bloody Grylls.
It's only Bloody Dunnets.
It's only Bloody Dunnets!
Bloody Dunnets!
Wow.
Look at you guys.
I thought I smelled bad.
I mean, that is the smell of honest hard work.
Yeah, glad to see you.
Thanks for coming back.
I'm glad I made it to the end.
I am super, super, super glad I made it to the end.
Well done, you guys.
Wow.
It's like you've been through a war zone.
But those smiles tell a story.
So how are you feeling?
Fantastic.
Glad to see you now.
Yeah.
Glad to see you.
As a band of brothers, it's not a band of brothers anymore.
It's a family.
Love them and hate them.
They're here forever with you.
And it was fantastic.
So we're going to get you off the island.
One last thing you guys want to do?
Yes.
Woo!
Come on, boys.
Come on, guys.
Kyle, you started this fire.
You tell us when to end it, pal.
I'm proud to say that I've made it here with you guys.
Ocean's 11ters.
Let's quench the fire.
Quench the fire, guys.
Woo!
Get in there.
Yes?
I think what's interesting is that you realize they've actually
become a really tight unit.
You know, that's why there's emotion at the end when they're
hugging each other, because they've been through the fire
together, and have come out of it stronger.
Well done, boys.
Let's go, boys.
If I got that chance again, give me about a year or half a year, I'll do it again.
But if you ask me to do it tomorrow, I'll probably tell you to piss off.
Just because you're over 40, just because you're over 50, just because you're almost 60, doesn't mean you're spent.
A can-do attitude goes a long way in this life.
Is that Will? Is that Will?
That's William!
That's him in this!
Oh, that's so good.
Wow, you all stink!
I couldn't let you guys get to the end without me.
Hello, is that you?
Hi, I'm fine, you?
It's absolutely brilliant, babe.
Oh God, your voice is beautiful.
Hello?
Is that Bobby?
Yeah.
Oh, Bobby!
Bobby, I need to hear from you.
It'sng
It's provided a look at overall.
You know, they've built community, they have learnt have compassionate and a care for each other.
A respect for each other, they've worked their nuts off.
They've understood the heart of survival isn't about knowledge.
It's about embracing failure, making mistakes and never giving up.
And that's why, at the end of it, what I've done is inspiring.
they've gone through a journey together and come out of it stronger tighter and
it's why they've learned the beginning of a mastery over this environment
they can call themselves survivors they've earned it the hard way
you